foreign
[Music]
[Music]
14 pro so this might be a little bit
inside baseball but typically when
you're testing a new product an
unreleased product from Apple they tell
you to keep the testing a secret don't
let anyone know you have it don't
display it publicly don't show it to
anyone that would be breaking the NDA
and that's still true about this new
iPhone 14 pro but I'll tell you what I
was able to walk around take pictures
text people pay for things with Apple
pay and nobody even blinked an eye
because it looks
exactly the same as the iPhone 13 Pro
this is still of course a new phone
though for a new year and so really
there are three major things that are
new with the 14 pro those being the
internals
the display
and the cameras and so I'm going to sort
of chapter those things off to go over
each of them but of course also worth
mentioning is this new MKBHD Edition
Chevron hoodie finally finally available
in the MKBHD store mkbhd.com it's very
comfortable but also hoodie season
[Music]
yeah on and on
so there's not a whole lot of new pieces
in this new phone but there's
technically more in this one than the
Baseline iPhone 14 because this one
actually gets the Silicon upgrade to the
new a16 bionic and six gigs of RAM top
of the line new four nanometer system on
a chip from Apple you could tell though
when they gave the presentation in the
keynote that it must be a pretty minor
bump from the a15 bionic because they
went straight to comparing it to the a13
bionic from a couple years ago in real
life though so far it's benchmarked very
similar to an a15 bionic just slightly
above as expected and that's meant for
me Rock Solid performance fluid
animations and are pretty reliable
all-day battery life from both the 14
pro and 14 pro Max but I'm going to get
more into battery in a minute also
technically new to the internals is a
new set of sensors it's an improved
gyroscope and a better accelerometer to
be able to tell if you've been in a car
crash or Not Crash detection
cool feature so it'll detect if you've
been in a car crash or not and then if
you don't respond to the prompts on
screen it'll automatically call
Emergency Services great I'm not going
to test that I'm sure some other
YouTubers will find a way to test it but
actually my question really was like
okay if you're going to test it what
sort of things do you test and I guess
the answer is accidental triggers like
you know how you'll if you run up a
flight of stairs or something and you
have automatic workout detection on the
Apple watch it'll go oh have you started
a workout because you've got an elevated
heart rate and you just started to
running no just me I don't know I was
just wondering if there's other times I
might accidentally think that's
something else like a car crash might
have happened maybe you've got a dbrand
case on it and you just drop it on the
floor or something I don't know it hits
the ground hard enough thinks it might
have crashed but then the more you look
at it the more you realize there's a
bunch of different sensors and factors
where it sees okay your GPS location was
going 60 miles an hour until it hit zero
miles an hour and the microphones heard
a loud noise and the barometric pressure
changed when the airbags went off and
also the gyroscope saw that there was a
hard stopping force it knows you run a
car crash one more thing that used to be
in the iPhone that's not anymore and
this one is a physical SIM card tray
this is actually for the US only and
these phones are now e-sim only esim
isn't exactly a new thing but not having
a physical SIM tray anymore does have
its pros and cons pros mainly being okay
it's one less place for water to get in
one less moving part but cons being that
for international travel if you just
wanted to grab a SIM card real quick
instead of going through the carriers
that's no longer nearly as easy I'm
going to keep an eye on this because I
imagine Apple intends to eventually
expand this to all iPhones instead of
what it's now which is just starting in
the US only but then the last internal
change for the iPhone 14s all of them is
satellite connectivity this is an edge
case extra feature that you're honestly
hoping you never ever have to use but in
the off chance that you're stranded
somewhere with absolutely no cellular
service at all you're nowhere near a
cell tower the iPhone's antenna is now
impressively can also communicate with
straight up satellites instead of cell
towers so it'll take longer and you'll
need a clear view of the sky and the UI
will literally help you point your phone
at a certain satellite overhead but it
will let you send messages to a
dispatcher or local emergency services
to help get to your location and what
you need help with that is also pretty
clutch I will also not be testing that
but that's it for internals uh notice I
didn't talk much about the externals
like I usually do in phone reviews
because if we're being honest they're
pretty much the same uh there are some
new colors the space black which is my
favorite in years and there's also a new
purple color from certain angles you can
hardly even tell it's purple but if it
hits the light you know for a pro phone
that's a solid purple I guess really
only the camera bumps change they are
definitely slightly larger and thicker
than the 13 Pros but bottom line is when
an iPhone 13 Pro can fit in an iPhone 14
Pro's case and you know it's pretty
close
in return okay so now we're really
getting into the meat of what you really
start to notice on these new phones
iPhone 14 pro and 14 pro Max have some
slightly updated 6.1 inch and 6.7 inch
OLED displays respectively so there's
still excellent displays on paper with
slightly thinner bezels that you won't
notice and slightly higher resolution
that you also won't notice and an even
higher brighter 2000 nits Peak
brightness that you absolutely will
notice when looking at the phone on like
a bright sunny day it looks great at 100
out in the sun but the two things you'll
notice the most often here are the
dynamic Island and the always-on display
the always-on display is the perfect
example of the classic apple late mover
strategy like this is not a new feature
this has been on hundreds of phones
before for many years but now it's
finally coming to an iPhone and so it's
being done the apple way this time the
thing is I don't really know that
there's any advantages to this apple way
so the always on display looks like this
so you hit the power button you sleep
the phone you put it down the brightness
drops the ltpo OLED display goes all the
way down to one Hertz and you get to see
the clock and notifications roll in as
if your lock screen is still on just at
a lower brightness this is a pretty
bright always-on display though you can
see that right like it you get used to
it after a few days but I constantly was
looking over at my phone on my desk
thinking it was still on which is like a
lower brightness
but yeah it looks like that all the time
the transition from the home screen to
the always on display is really nice
it's got this smooth fade animation and
I think that's the Apple Way like the
clock if it's behind something will
graduate to the front of the oasan
display and it maintains all the colors
and skin tones and whatever wallpaper
you were using so it's not faded or
black and white you still have all your
color if you've got music playing then
your album art is front and center it is
extra beautiful but I don't really care
about any of that to be honest and
there's also no extra customization like
I've seen some really creative always-on
displays over the years that let me
customize and dial in even differently
from the lock screen and I really love
using them apples is just a toggle in
the display settings on or off that's it
me personally I'm gonna be turning it
off on this phone because it also seems
to be affecting battery life slightly
more than I expected now the always-on
display specifically doesn't show up in
the battery settings so I'm kind of just
estimating here based on my behavior
everything else looks normal but I am
getting slightly worse battery life than
I've expected and then I've had on the
13 Pro for the past year and so I assume
that's this that's a little extra
brightness gone a long way it does still
know when to turn off don't get me wrong
if it's in a pocket it turns off if
you're in sleep mode it turns off even
when you have an Apple Watch on and you
walk far enough away from the phone that
it knows you can't see it anymore it
turns off the always-on display but it
does just sit here on my desk all day
showing me stuff and I I don't really
use it all that much so yeah I'm gonna
pass but you know what is new on the
screen that I absolutely love and will
never pass on the dynamic Island baby
what a terrible name they felt the need
to name the notch it is such a minor
feature in the grand scheme of using a
phone but it's a good one it's a really
good one so here's what's happening
remember the rumors of the new Pro
iPhone replacing the notch with an eye
shaped cutout in the top of the display
with all those renders people made well
that's actually what this is it has one
circular cut out on the right for a new
selfie camera and one pill-shaped cutout
on the left for the new face ID Hardware
which they've shrunk down by about 30
percent to fill in this smaller area and
then instead of just doing that Apple
has cleverly decided to fill in the gap
between them with black pixels and make
it one big pill so then the idea is
Apple would much rather think about the
pill as software than Hardware so they
built a whole bunch of software features
around it so it just has a resting state
like this which doesn't show up in
screenshots or screen recordings it's
just a gap but there are about 30
different things that it does to
indicate ongoing activities and
background activities and things that
are all beautifully animated and super
smooth these fluid physics it's so
friendly and approachable and all of
these things that it does show up in
screenshots and Screen recordings the
best part is pretty much everything
works straight out the box as you'd
expect it to so I had this moment during
the first impressions video where I was
like oh can't wait for Apple music to
use it but then Spotify to take like a
year and a half to actually update their
app to work with this but nope
everything works straight out the box
including Spotify because that already
uses the now playing API they already
had a lock screen widget same with
SoundCloud same with YouTube music and
Pocket Casts so you have album art and
the color matching waveform up there
while the media is playing if you tap it
it'll open the app that's playing and if
you long press it you actually get a
widget that pops up with some media
controls I can scrub and everything
pretty much the exact same widget that
would appear in the lock screen so this
feels kind of backwards I think a tap
should open the widget and then a long
press should open the app and that would
just make more sense but whatever the
point is it just works right off the rip
matter of fact here's everything that
the dynamic Island does right out the
box on day one so it does system alerts
like for incoming calls connecting air
pods plugging into a charger switching
the ringer to silent mode or volume on
face ID unlocking connecting air pods
and a whole bunch more there's our full
list and then it's also a UI for live
activities happening in the background
so an ongoing call or music playing in
the background any media a timer
counting down Maps directions as you
navigate in the background what voice
memos recording screen recording all
that stuff so here's a full list of that
as well and then any third-party app
that uses the now playing or call Kit
apis which there are many it also has a
little spot for the indicator for
microphone and camera access right in
between the pill and the cutout it
really becomes next level when you have
multiple background activities happening
at once because then it low-key kind of
becomes like a multitasking app switcher
at the top of your phone so one
background activity looks like this but
then if I have a second one if I go
start a new background activity it
splits the island into two so now you
can pick between them and then quickly
swap between them with a single touch
that's so sick I think as cheesy as the
name is like I'm about done saying the
words Dynamic Island out loud but I
think this will be one of the most
copied features in the smartphone World
in like 18 months pretty much guarantee
it like we even already saw some MIUI
mods on Twitter where people trying this
on other phones but the thing is it's
going to be surprisingly hard to copy it
exactly like this on this level it seems
pretty innocuous pretty simple but there
is a lot going on here like there's a
new display engine in the a16 bionic
that handles all these animations and
there's a lot of them that really pull
this whole thing together there's
physics to it you just you poke the cut
out and it wobbles and moves around a
little like it's alive and since there
are real cutouts like holes in the
display for the camera and the face ID
system it has to be touch sensitive in
areas around the actual cutout so that
it can still register Taps when you
touch a dead zone on the screen and for
the most part it works pretty well is
this a game changing feature in a phone
for most people no is this a reason to
get one phone over another
I don't think so no not really is this a
nice quality of life touch that a lot of
people will think is really cool and
really like
yeah yeah I think that's true is this
feature technically invented by LG seven
years ago with the top screen on the LG
V10
yes
absolutely
[Music]
all right if you watch enough iPhone
presentations then you know that the pro
iPhone really is and has been all about
the cameras fun fact they spent 23
minutes on stage at the September event
talking about the iPhone 14 pro and
seven of those minutes about 33 percent
we're just talking about the camera and
so this is the biggest change at least
on paper that's been made to the iPhone
camera in many years look at this graph
this is a graph of the megapixel count
of every iPhone camera since they first
came out they've been confidently
repeating the 12 megapixel sensors since
the iPhone 6s but this year we got a
leap we got the leap the primary camera
on the iPhone 14 pro is now a new 48
megapixel sensor it's 65 percent larger
than the one we had on the 12 Pro it has
a second generation Focus Shift Optical
image stabilization 100 Focus pixels and
sits behind a new f 1.78 lens I think we
can all agree that's a great set of
specs that we expect great imagery from
but really The more I've been playing
with it it's just more about what the
new 48 megapixel sensor enables that's
so great so a new larger 48 megapixel
sensor that's going to bend down to 12
megapixels for all your normal photos
but you do get the benefits of sharpness
and more light Gathering From a larger
sensor that also gives you faster
shutter speeds to freeze motion more
often in non-perfect conditions and it
lets me take low light photos with a
shorter shutter time which is very
convenient but the larger sensor also
gives you a really nice shallow natural
depth of field without portrait mode
more than we've ever seen from an iPhone
camera now other phones I've seen do
this just as well but it presents a new
set of challenges like fringing and
autofocus but I've been very impressed
with how well the iPhone deals with both
not a whole ton of fringing on close-up
subjects and 100 coverage with Focus
pixels has been pretty locked in on
tracking subjects and keeping things in
Focus even with the shallow depth of
field my only complaint really is the
pretty weak minimum Focus distance
things get blurred when you get close to
the primary camera so you got to switch
to the macro mode pretty early luckily
the ultra wide has some improvements too
so that's not the end of the world
then a 48 megapixel sensor also enables
this new 2x button doesn't seem like
that huge of a deal but it's literally
just cropping in on the middle 12
megapixels of this huge sensor so it's
essentially like an optical zoom it's
not like you're going to lose quality
the way anything less than 3x would have
been before on iPhones because it was
cropping into an already 12 megapixel
image the 48 megapixel sensor also
enables this new action mode and video
which is this super aggressive
stabilization for really shaky video and
it does this with a pretty heavy crop
but it's also able to still shoot in up
to 2.8 K in this mode a little Pro tip
it defaults to the 0.5 x camera it's
much noisier when you do this so so I I
do recommend switching back to the
primary for it and then if you're
running around chasing a subject or even
pulling it out a car window or just
anytime you need some pretty heavy
stabilization this is definitely nice to
have if you want the full 48 megapixel
files you can shoot in Pro raw and it
will kick out 50 60 70 megabyte dng
files which have a lot of detail and
latitude to push around in Lightroom and
make them look better than the straight
out of Camera 12 megapixel shots but
I'll leave that to the Peter McKinnon's
and Tyler stalman's or many other
photography creators I know are going to
put this to the test one thing they
didn't do with the new 48 megapixel
sensor is 8k video they could have
they've not been able to until they
crossed the 30 megapixel threshold they
got to 48 they didn't do it that of
course would also probably still be
pretty tough considering the max iPhone
is still one terabyte which sounds like
a lot but then you're also working with
huge five six gig per minute prores
files that take forever to get off the
iPhone via this lightning port in the
slow speeds and they should probably
just switch to USBC and that's a whole
rant for another day so I'll just stop
it there but just know
no AK video straight from the iPhone's
camera I think I can honestly safely
though put the iPhone 14 pro as the best
camera system in any phone in 2022.
don't get me wrong it's not perfect it
can definitely over bake HDR sometimes
in some harsh shooting conditions and
the new selfie camera which now has 12
megapixels and autofocus while it
handles a variety of focal lengths much
better and is sharper overall it still
has a tendency to overexpose people with
dark skin constantly I would know but if
I'm just looking for the overall
versatility of the whole camera system
you know the shutter speed improvements
the quality of the photos the great
autofocus the color consistency between
the three different cameras the overall
image processing pipeline improvements
that have made the ultra wide much more
usable and less noisy and low light and
then of course the prores video that I'm
literally actively running an entire
YouTube channel with then yeah I'm
pretty comfortable calling this the
camera King again and yes I am going to
be shooting the new autofocus video with
the iPhone 14 Pros cameras so if you
want to large helping of sample footage
that's going to be the place to go go
subscribe over there plus the car is
going to be that's a fun one it's going
to be a good video so don't miss it
anyway oh also guess what guess what
cinematic mode now supports
30 FPS
huh
that's funny
Checkmate 24 FPS stands uh no but also I
don't think I'm gonna be using cinematic
mode that much because the natural depth
of field is so good on the primary
camera but yeah 30 FPS cinematic now
also remember how all those event
invites went out a couple weeks ago and
the theme was far out and there were all
these stars and we thought oh they're
going to get an astrophotography mode
like a nighttime photography type thing
uh that didn't happen turned out they
were like hinting at the satellite
connectivity but like the iPhone still
gets crushed when it comes to some of
the like super low light nighttime
shooting and especially astrophotography
so I'm kind of bummed that we didn't get
that but otherwise yeah complete camera
[Music]
so the iPhone 14 pro is still a thousand
dollars and the 14 pro Max is still
eleven hundred dollars to start so they
are the absolute best phones Apple makes
right now and there's going to be a lot
of people considering an upgrade so is
it worth it well in the landscape of
other phones you could get for one
thousand dollars this one's gonna be
competitive it's going to have the best
camera of the bunch I think uh it's
gonna have one of the best brightest
most responsive displays of any of those
phones it's also going to have a dynamic
Island however you feel about that but
also it's going to have the classic
Suite of iPhone stuff iMessage FaceTime
Classics but there definitely isn't any
any flashy or any Crazy Design or
Hardware Innovation Happening Here There
is nothing folding in half there is no
super fast charging or some massive
battery size Improvement the new colors
which you've seen are like yeah you can
kind of tell that they're a little
different looking but this is a very
refined update and so really the truth
is if you have an iPhone 11 or later at
this point then the new iOS 16 update
pushing out to your phone right now is
gonna make just as big of a difference
to the user experience of using your
phone as getting the new phone probably
would so yeah I'd say you know the new
lock screen the haptic keyboard all this
stuff I did a video on all the new
features you can check that out but yeah
this is a really good phone you should
get it if you either want the latest and
greatest and best of a smartphone camera
available right now or if you've just
got a thousand dollar hole in your
pocket burning away and you just have to
have the latest and greatest pro iPhone
that's what this is if you're not trying
to get the newest iPhone then you can
skip the upgrade it and fix your current
phone with parts and tools by this
video's sponsor iFixit they make it
super easy with free repair guides and
tear Downs on their channel it's not as
hard as it looks also if you want to see
the inside of your phone before you try
to fix it check out ifixit's channel so
you can see their iPhone 14 tear down
when they take apart Tech so you can
learn how to fix it yourself so you can
check them out at the link below one
sustainability note I found interesting
the iPhone 14s now across the board have
a slightly improved repairability design
the glass on the back is now separate
from the components underneath
very nice but either way that's been it
thanks for watching definitely get
subscribed to see the straight up
standard iPhone 14 review and that comes
out also the Apple watch Ultra and that
comes out and about a thousand other
things that are all working on here at
the studio because it's Tech Timber
there's a lot happening
see you in the next one
peace
[Music]